Le Skelam, le bateau de Parcs
Canada, nous attend à lriririna
près de Sydney, sur l'île de
Vancouver.
Il faudra environ une heure
pour se rendre sur les berges
de l
du parc national des îles-Gulf.
C'est un endroit paisible où
les gens viennent aujourd'hui
du soleil. Mais il y a un
clclcle, cette île était plutôt
connue comme l'île de la mort.
Ces gens étaient pratiquement
tous origieseses de Chine.
Entre 1891 et 1924, une
cinquantaine de personnes ont
île. À l'époque où la ville
detototoria était responsable
du Lazaret, ces établissements
où on isole des maladese e e e e
D'Arcy étaient complètement
laissés à eux-mêmes.
Au moins une douzaine
Ce que nous sommes venus
visiter, ce  l l les ruines
de la maison du gardien.
En 1907, lorsque
le contrôle de ce qui était
essellllllement une colonie
lépreuse, les conditions ont
changé et du personnel de soins,
lui, a persisté.
Les malades ont donc été
transférés sur une petite
La sociologue Renisa Mawani
s'intéresse à cette périoaiaiai.
Une histoire qui l'a choquée.
À la mêmeququque, d'autres
patients atteints de la maladie
de Hansen étaient envoyés dans
où ils y recevaient des soins.
Leur difncncnce?
Ils étaient Blancs.
A A Aujourd'hui sur l'île,
la nature a repris ses droits.
Le Lazaret a été réduit enlolol.
Seules les ruines de la maison
du gardien et une petite plaque
installée par la Ville de
Victoria peuvent encdedededededp
qualifient être l'une des
pages les plus sombres
du racisme au Canada.
Ici Sarah Xadadadadadadadadadac